i love to give a final five if you'll do
it with me because i just love to ask
some rando questions all right let's
play all right you ready yeah time for
the final five
[Applause]
all right so number one you're an
aquaman but if you had a superpower what
would it be
it would be
the
ability to
fly
i mean that
can i say that dude like can i still say
fly is it still is it not bored is it
boring to say fly i don't think it would
ever be it'd be so nice to just be able
to fly like in the summertime i go on
vacations whenever i want without you
know paying for the tickets and
that's what i want to do i want to fly
to islands
all right number two
um
give me your recent random google search
shout out laughing there
um how does time work
yeah
i'm trying to figure out how time works
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna tell you a piece of the truth
all right i was um i was up last night
and i was uh
trying to figure out how time works
because sometimes you just you're just
sitting there and you're like wait a
minute
how how does this all work like and and
what if i could stop it and what if i
can control this
you know
and i was inspired to try to slow time
down i'm still working on it i still got
to figure it out but keep us posted i
will
see these are the answers you don't get
otherwise thank you yeah okay uh number
three uh who is your first celebrity
crush
it was tinkerbell
it was tinkerbell was it the little ball
on her tush was it the
little like fairy wing she flies it
wasn't she
she fly i mean she she had it she just
had it all going on and then when you
clap like i forget what happens it was
you know you just clap for her and yeah
you know she wanted her strong woman who
flies who a strong woman who flies and
who loves the son of applause because
that's that you know that's that's nice
too it's nice to be able to
applaud your lady we like it here yeah
yeah each other absolutely we're all
very encouraging
um
number four best mistake you've ever
made
i want to say something about a recipe
right when i just like i made a mistake
and put the wrong seasoning and then
some type of recipe and it turned out to
be brilliant but i don't i don't have
that i don't have that story no but
that's perfect yeah because you're right
we that's so relatable and inspired i
love it i think you just take credit for
it you say i meant to do that um okay
number five your pump up song right now
do host
by uh ramstein anybody know that yeah
there we go okay we're just cheering you
on in work and in life ambulance is in
theaters starting april 8th you will fly
and you will feel something that most
movies are not capable of making you
feel i will say that so thank you so
much
[Music]
you